et maintenant
voici vl5
et ben voilà ce que demande le peuple
daniel jean marc richard bondo réel 5
vous êtes effectivement un groupe issu
de la télé réalité puisque vous êtes
sortis de popstars 2001 sur m6 vous êtes
5 et au départ il y avait 4000 candidate
quand même bien observer parce que ce
n'était pas facile du premier coup on va
commencer la présentation dans le fab
éthique qui avec sandra alors alexandre
guérini s'est rangé comme ça les arrange
et alors
alexandra donc c'est vous bonsoir on
vous appelle aussi à l'ex bilou nini
outtara taille s'est passé si vous êtes
un pirate si vous êtes un peu de radio
c'est vrai alexandra faisait 26 ans vous
mesurer à m 59 c'est pas aux années 50
on avait bien vu
où
je vous demande de vous arrêter alors le
groupe continue des droits tv est une
partie des grosses pire sanctionner les
images sur le ventre oui aussi une rose
alors vous avez quelqu'un en ce moment
où il cherchait quelqu'un parce qu'ici
on a varié larusso vous avez déjà puis
on n'a plus jamais
r on a tellement vous êtes tout seul oui
mais c'est pas grave non mais ya rien eu
des millions de gens qui vous regardent
et votre numéro de portable alors
alexandre à 26,59 célibataire ensuite
ensuite ensuite c'est clair claire keim
alias clairon alors 32 ans presse ahmed
57 encore plus petit qu avec sandra de
plus en plus ça va pire singh sur le nez
et tatouages vous c'est sur les pauses
vous avez une fille sur l'épaule ouais
c'est qu'elle fait c'est une fée c'est
celle qu'on vous vend son site
et j'avais été sur david dadge ces
appellations là bien sûr d'avoir blessé
le romain tout en même temps vous vous
avez quelqu'un dans votre vie répond pas
ce genre de questions générales l'avenir
ils veulent pas dire c'est qu'elles ont
fait rappelle toi ta copine dont était
fou ouais team team qui nous a menti à
l'époque elle rit quelqu'un qui mêle
avec quelqu'un voulait pas décevoir son
public comme hervé vilard fazila
quelqu'un merveilleux avril à quelqu'un
et pour pas des semences en libye qui
dit il est tout seul voilà bien alors
que ma vie makoko très mignonne coralie
alors qu'ils ont à lui ils veulent c
sont beaucoup plus grandes que c'est
encore un mètre soixante ces normes du
vin de connie que certains camps et les
cocos vous savez limites et muriel robin
c'est de voir une profonde avec son
répondeur de murray rothbard je ne suis
pas là à grax soins de soins l'envié
c'est notre message par le bip sonore
merci d'avoir appris au revoir et à très
bientôt un sibyllin
m
vous faites le sirop d'orgeat raquette
très inquiets nous fait véronique sanson
aussi et unique samson et regarde la
comelle hébert et tout cela sans le cerf
c'est un don miraculeux très bien je
trouve qu'elle le fait mieux que la vrai
bon vous je sais que vous avez quelqu'un
je vous pose pas la question
wee aa b qui s'est du coup voilà vous
avez quelqu'un vous connaissez la
discrétion de cette émission je vais pas
commencer à raconter votre vie privée
n'ont jamais acheté un mac et lydie
alias sacha 26 ans 1 mètre 63 c'est la
gérante
c'est le schéma piercing ou h&h le rhône
ont été des millions à 1,8 ghz une
fresque
non non 5 mais c'est à des endroits très
alarmant non mais alors dit alors ya un
an nombre et le nombril ou selon moi il
ya encore des 12es vous avez quelqu'un
dans votre vie bien sûr toujours lui
jeremy ce nom il est où là c'est sûr il
a dit que tu veux croire et oui quelles
preuves à qui la maison j'ai déjà parlé
il a intérêt d'être à la mise mais là il
peut ne pas être à la maison n'a aucun
moyen de vérifier la passe qu'il garde
mon chien à cléo au nom des jeux
il examine ça avec quelques uns avec les
autres et sur moi la sas complet bon
marjorie alias margot 24 heures la règle
c'est la supergéante sinon vous pourriez
faire du basket vous mesurez 1 m 65 24
ans 1 m 65 piercing au nombril
1 vous êtes tout pire c'est que ça peut
être dangereux
oui oui mais ça a été fait avec des
précautions alors vous avez un bon alors
vous savez limitée du cac où je ne pense
pas avoir le don forcément des mutés
elie kakou moment je vois revenir à
dakar parce que je vais pouvoir faire
des commentaires
un corsaire je trouve ça bien à toi ah
ben moi je moi non mais limitation
muriel robin ou de véronique sanson
était mieux quand même non ah oui
non moi je suis pas imitatrice nord fait
refaire une fois énormément et qu il
faut qu on y arrive à cet hélico ou d'un
gala c'est mieux pas rigoler pour elie
kakou moi j'aimais beaucoup vos chez moi
si énormément
bon et puis avec eddy depuis sept ans
voilà les à ce passe bien
ah ben oui c'est que c'est ans comme un
cap c'était un cap décisif c'est vrai
que beaucoup de couples et vous vous
allez passer la barrière 17 ans eh ben
je sais pas on va voir
l'avenir nous dira comment vous appelez
les l5
non je te conseille le dvd parce qu'un
bonus où elles prennent leur douche je
suis bien remplie que c'est fort quand
vous êtes toutes les 5 à poil sous la
douche franchement rien que pour ça je
conseille à tous nos amis vous savez
quoi
orlando exige le dvd dit magnéto serge
vous regarder la caméra